Narrator:
TONIGHT ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE CELEBRATE
MILLENNIAL ENTREPRENEURS.
WHO'S READY TO WAX UP THEIR
BOARD AND RIDE THIS TASTY WAVE?
Narrator:
AND IN A VERY SPECIAL UPDATE,
THE SHARKS ARE INVITED
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE GOT INNOVATORS AND INVESTORS,
EVEN GOT A FEW SHARKS.
Narrator: IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT TO START,
GROW, OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESSES.
THE PROBLEM IS I'M MAKING IT
OUT OF A FIVE-GALLON
BUCKET RIGHT NOW.
YOU REALLY ARE?
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
TEASE ME FOR A SECOND.
HOLD ON.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
THE RIGHT OFFER.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
SHARK FIGHT,
SHARK FIGHT.
THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET THE
FULL AMOUNT THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
IT'S A DOG.
SHOOT IT, BURN IT,
GET RID OF IT,
DO SOMETHING ELSE
WITH YOUR TIME.
WE CAN EASILY BE
AT $40 MILLION, $50 MILLION.
-WOW.
-I'LL DO $1 MILLION FOR 17.5%.
O'Leary:
ROBERT, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I THINK
YOU NEED MORE MONEY.
ARE YOU SPEED DATING
OR GIVING HIM AN OFFER?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF THE WORLD'S
PREEMINENT CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WITH A SOLUTION TO THE DREADED
CHORE OF DOING LAUNDRY.
♪♪
HEY, SHARKS,
MY NAME IS MAXWELL COHEN.
I'M FROM NEW YORK CITY,
AND MY COMPANY IS AfreSHeet.
I'M SEEKING $100,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF MY BUSINESS.
LYDIA HERE, SHE'S A BUSY WOMAN.
SHE'S A FULL-TIME
COLLEGE STUDENT,
HAS A PART-TIME JOB
IN THE EVENING.
WHO HAS TIME
TO WASH THEIR SHEETS?
[ LAUGHS ]
DORM BEDS ARE USED
FOR MORE THAN JUST SLEEPING.
THEY'RE USED AS A KITCHEN,
A DESK, A DINING ROOM TABLE --
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING.
LUCKILY FOR LYDIA,
SHE SLEEPS ON AfreSHeet.
AfreSHeet'S THE WORLD'S FIRST
AND ONLY FITTED BED SHEET
WITH PEEL-AWAY
DISPOSABLE TOP LAYERS.
WHEN YOU SOIL YOUR BED...
...YOU PEEL OFF THAT LAYER
TO INSTANTLY REVEAL A BRAND-NEW
LAYER BENEATH.
[ LAUGHS ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
OH, AND THIS MESS?
YOU THROW IT RIGHT
IN THE RECYCLING BIN.
HEY, IF THERE HAPPENS TO BE
ANOTHER MESS, DO NOT PANIC.
AfreSHeet'S GOT SEVEN PEEL-AWAY,
DISPOSABLE TOP LAYERS.
THERE IS SO MANY DIFFERENT USES
FOR AfreSHeet, SO MOM,
DON'T SEND YOUR KID OFF
TO COLLEGE
HOPING ONE DAY
THEY'LL WASH THEIR SHEET.
AfreSHeet.
TODDLER'S NOT FEELING WELL
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT?
AfreSHeet.
FRIEND'S COMING TO VISIT?
SHARKS, I STARTED THIS COMPANY
WHILE I WAS IN COLLEGE
AND I'VE POURED A LOT OF BLOOD,
SWEAT, AND TEARS INTO THIS
BUSINESS.
FORTUNATELY FOR ME, I CAN PEEL
IT ALL AWAY WITH AfreSHeet.
[ CHUCKLES ]
O'Leary:
MAXWELL, WHAT'S IT MADE OF?
IT IS MADE OUT
OF POLYESTER.
DO YOU HAVE SAMPLES
FOR US TO TOUCH?
OF COURSE.
MAX, POLYESTER
DOESN'T BREATHE.
SO, THIS IS THE NEWEST VERSION
OF THE SHEET.
THIS IS MADE OUT OF THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF POLYESTER.
IT DOESN'T FEEL GREAT.
DON'T PEOPLE WANT
A SOFT SHEET TO SLEEP ON?
THIS FEELS CLINICAL.
WE'RE NOT COMPETING
WITH EGYPTIAN COTTON.
WE ARE HERE FOR PRACTICALITY
AND CONVENIENCE.
BUT IT DOESN'T BREATHE,
RIGHT?
IT IS VERY BREATHABLE.
[ BLOWS ]
SO, IT'S NOT AS BREATHABLE
AS CONVENTIONAL BED SHEETS.
IT'S NOT BREATHING, MAX.
THERE'S NO WAY
I CAN BLOW THROUGH THIS.
KEVIN, IS THAT
A SCIENTIFIC TEST?
[ BLOWS ]
-YEAH.
-IT IS.
IT'S SORT OF LIKE PAPER,
THOUGH,
BECAUSE I JUST POKED
MY FINGER THROUGH IT.
HOW MUCH DO YOU HAVE
IN SALES?
Herjavec:
YEAH, WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD?
SO, I'VE SOLD A LITTLE OVER
400 AfreSHeetS.
-THE FIRST GENERATION --
-400,000?
NO, 400.
WE'RE JUST A START-UP.
-NO KIDDING.
-HOW MUCH DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
I SELL THEM FOR $29.95
FOR A TWIN EXTRA LONG.
I COULD SEE A BIG MARKET
FOR IT, ACTUALLY.
I MEAN, I'M SURPRISED
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD MORE.
I COULD SEE IT IN HOSPITALS.
-YES.
ANYWHERE WHERE THERE'S MORE
OF A CLINICAL APPLICATION.
YEAH.
HAVE YOU APPROACHED
THOSE KIND OF MARKETS?
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF INTEREST
FROM SUMMER CAMPS,
ELDERLY HOMES.
WE'RE IN THE WORKS WITH A BUNCH
OF THEM RIGHT NOW.
WE WERE JUST
AT A GIANT COLLEGE EXPO.
LOTS OF BUZZ.
-LOTS OF ORDERS?
SO, WE'RE WAITING FOR THE NEWEST
SHIPMENT TO COME IN.
IT IS ON ITS WAY.
WE'RE ACTUALLY HELD UP
IN CUSTOMS RIGHT NOW.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WROTE PURCHASE
ORDERS, THOUGH, AT THE SHOW?
SO, WE'RE SUCH A NEW PRODUCT,
IT'S ONE OF THOSE IDEAS,
IT'S -- YOU HAVE TO WRAP
YOUR HEAD AROUND IT.
AND NOBODY'S CHANGED THE BED
SHEET FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
SO,
THEY DIDN'T ORDER.
SO, NOT YET.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY
IS INTO THIS COMPANY?
SO, I INVESTED
TO START THIS BUSINESS
ALL OF MY BAR MITZVAH MONEY.
HOW MUCH WAS THAT?
I HAD ABOUT
A LITTLE OVER $12,000.
WOW.
WHAT'S IT COST YOU
TO MAKE ONE $29.95 PACKAGE?
THAT ONE
IS A LITTLE OVER $7.
WE'RE WORKING ON NEW BETTER
MATERIALS THAT ARE --
MAX,
THERE'S VERY MANY LARGE
BIG-BOX RETAILERS
THAT SELL SHEETS.
YEAH.
HAVE YOU SHOWN ANY
OF THEM THIS PRODUCT?
SO, I PITCHED SOMEBODY
AT BED BATH & BEYOND.
AND?
THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO BE THE PEOPLE
TO INTRODUCE IT TO THE WORLD.
-OOH.
IT'S NOT AS SOFT
AS THEY WANT IT TO BE.
HMM.
SO, EVERYBODY LOVES THE IDEA,
AND SAID
"THE IDEA IS BRILLIANT."
THEY SAID THE IDEA
IS BRILLIANT.
YEAH, BUT YOUR BUSINESS
IS NOT RETAIL.
-YOUR BUSINESS IS INSTITUTIONAL.
-RIGHT.
SO, OVERSEAS,
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF INTEREST.
WE'VE BEEN
IN SOUTH AFRICAN HOSPITALS
AND SOUTH AFRICAN AMBULANCES.
IN AMERICA, WE'RE NOT PUSHING
TOWARDS HOSPITALS --
HOW BIG IS THE SOUTH AFRICAN
AMBULANCE MARKET?
[ LAUGHTER ]
MAX, YOU'RE FEELING YOUR WAY IN
AND YOU'RE LEARNING AS YOU GO,
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE READY FOR AN INVESTMENT,
AND CERTAINLY NOT
MY MONEY.
WITH THAT SAID, I'M OUT.
-HE'S OUT. THANK YOU.
-YOU'RE WELCOME.
Herjavec: MAX,
SOMETIMES PEOPLE COME OUT
AND I THINK, "WOW,
I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE."
IS IT BRILLIANT
OR IS IT NOT?
WHICH ONE IS THIS,
ROBERT?
I KNOW YOU'RE COMPARING IT
TO COTTON SHEETS
AND ALL THAT,
BUT THAT'S NOT HIS MARKET.
I MEAN,
I'VE GOT KIDS AT COLLEGE.
THEIR SHEETS ARE A MESS.
THEY WOULD BUY IT
AND RIP IT OFF.
I COULD SEE
ELDERLY HOMES.
WHY AREN'T THOSE PEOPLE
BUYING IT?
'CAUSE, TO ME,
IT SEEMS LIKE A SLAM DUNK.
YOU KNOW WHY
THEY'RE NOT BUYING IT, MAX?
IT'S A DOG.
I LOVE DOGS.
MAX, I'M GONNA
HELP YOU OUT HERE.
I HATE IT.
-PERFECT.
-I'M OUT.
SHOOT IT, BURN IT,
GET RID OF IT,
DO SOMETHING ELSE
WITH YOUR TIME.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
IF IT WAS SOFT
AND COMFORTABLE.
LIKE YOU SAID...
IT WOULD BE CALLED A SHEET
MADE OF COTTON.
...YOU WERE NEXT TO A BOOTH
THAT PROBABLY WAS MICRO FLEECE.
I LIKE SOMETHING
REALLY SOFT.
PEOPLE GO INTO THEIR BEDS
FOR COMFORT.
PEOPLE KNOW THEY HAVE
TO WASH THEIR SHEETS
BUT THEY DON'T
BECAUSE THEY'RE LAZY.
LORI,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THE CONCEPT.
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES,
CUSTOMERS LIE TO YOU.
THE BEST WAY TO GET RID OF
A SALESMAN IS TO TELL THEM WHAT?
-HOW TO GET RID OF A SALESMAN?
-YEAH.
YOU ACT LIKE MR. WONDERFUL
AND TELL THEM THEY'RE TERRIBLE.
NO.
NO, BECAUSE THEN
THEY KEEP OBJECTING.
THE BEST WAY
TO GET RID OF A SALESMAN
IS TO TELL THEM WHAT
THEY THINK THEY WANT TO HEAR --
THAT THEY MIGHT
BE GETTING AN ORDER.
GOT IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY ORDERS.
YOU'VE TESTED THE MARKET AND
THE MARKET'S SPEAKING TO YOU.
OH, THEY LOVE IT.
THEY LOVE IT.
-PEOPLE LOVE IT.
-WELL, NO, THEY DON'T LOVE IT.
THEY'RE NOT BEING GENEROUS.
IF THEY LOVED IT,
THEY WOULD BUY IT.
I GOT TO GO OUT BECAUSE
THE MARKET'S TELLING YOU THAT.
-THAT'S IT.
-THAT'S IT. THANKS, GUYS.
-GOOD LUCK. APPRECIATE IT.
-GOOD LUCK.
MAX, SHOOT IT.
-YOU LOVE IT.
-BEHIND THE BARN.
-THANKS, MR. WONDERFUL.
-MAX, THANK YOU.
-BYE.
-MAX, GOOD LUCK.
Cohen: I BELIEVE THIS IS
AN IDEA OF A LIFETIME.
IS IT A LITTLE HEARTBREAKING?
YEAH.
IS IT THEIR LOSS?
AM I EXCITED FOR THE FUTURE?
OH, YEAH.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A SOLUTION
TO A COMMON LAUNDRY MISHAP.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S NATE BARBERA.
AND I'M DES STOLAR.
AND WE'RE TEAM UNSHRINKIT
FROM BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS.
AND, TODAY, WE'RE ASKING
FOR $150,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
TO HELP US GROW OUR BUSINESS.
TODAY, WE'RE HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM.
SHRINKAGE.
CLOTHING SHRINKAGE,
THAT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
TELL THEM, DES.
MY SISTER
SAVED UP HER MONEY
TO GIVE ME
A GORGEOUS CASHMERE SWEATER.
I LOVED IT, I TREASURED IT,
AND THEN...
I SHRUNK IT.
WITH THE HELP OF CHEMISTRY,
WE'VE DEVELOPED A REVOLUTIONARY
NEW PRODUCT
THAT RELAXES WOOL FIBERS
AND ALLOWS THEM TO BE RETURNED
BACK TO THEIR ORIGINAL SIZE.
NOW, LET US SHOW YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
UNSHRINKIT WORKS
IN FOUR SIMPLE STEPS.
STEP ONE -- ADD UNSHRINKIT
TO A GALLON OF WATER.
STEP TWO --
ADD YOUR SWEATERS
AND LET THEM SOAK
FOR 30 MINUTES.
NOW, STEP THREE
IS THAT YOU RINSE OFF
THE SOLUTION
IN COLD RUNNING WATER.
UNSHRINKIT IS COLOR SAFE
AND HAND SAFE.
THE FOURTH AND FINAL STEP
IS THAT YOU RE-SHAPE
THAT FAVORITE GARMENT BACK
TO THE DESIRED SIZE,
AND THEN YOU LAY IT FLAT
TO DRY.
AND BY THE TIME
THAT SWEATER DRIES,
THE WOOL FIBERS HAVE LOCKED
BACK INTO THEIR ORIGINAL
ELONGATED CONFIGURATION
AND HAVE PERMANENTLY SAVED
YOUR SWEATER.
NOW, UNSHRINKIT WORKS
ON MERINO, CASHMERE,
LAMB'S WOOL, SMART WOOL,
YOU NAME IT.
SHARKS,
I AM STANDING HERE WEARING
THAT EXACT CASHMERE SWEATER
THAT I SAVED USING UNSHRINKIT.
I LOOK GOOD, DON'T I?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT WAS ONCE
AN UNFIXABLE LAUNDRY MISTAKE
IS NO LONGER A PROBLEM
WITH UNSHRINKIT.
IT IS LITERALLY
THE EMERGENCY SWEATER SAVER.
SO, SHARKS,
WHO'S READY TO MAKE A DEAL?
DES, HOW DO YOU STOP IT
FROM OVER GETTING BIG?
Greiner: YEAH, I WAS GONNA --
SO, THE WOOL FIBERS
WERE ALREADY MANUFACTURED
TO A CERTAIN LENGTH,
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
RETURNING IT TO THE LENGTH
IN WHICH IT WAS MANUFACTURED
AND NO MORE.
John: BUT I'M THINKING, LIKE,
IF SOMEBODY REALLY KNOWS
HOW TO CARE
FOR THEIR CLOTHES,
WHY WOULD THEY THINK
THEY'RE GONNA NEED THIS?
THIS IS KIND OF
AN AFTER A FACT.
RIGHT, SO, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT BROUGHT US
TO THIS SPACE ALTOGETHER
WAS THAT I SHRUNK THAT SWEATER,
AND I'M THINKING I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME SORT OF SOLUTION
ON THE MARKET FOR THIS.
I STARTED LOOKING,
AND THERE'S NOTHING --
NO SORT OF COMMERCIALIZED REMEDY
FOR THIS.
BUT WHAT SURPRISED ME WAS
THAT THERE WERE MILLIONS
OF YouTube VIEWS OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT VIDEOS --
DO IT YOURSELF.
CAN YOU TRY TO FIX THIS?
ARE THERE HOME REMEDIES?
SO, KNOWING
THAT THERE WAS A MARKET THERE,
THOUSANDS OF WEB PAGES,
MILLIONS OF YouTube VIEWS,
I GOT BACK TO SCHOOL,
PARTNERED WITH SOME PEOPLE,
AND SAID, "WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY CREATE SOMETHING."
AND WE'VE SOLD 5,000 UNITS,
GENERATING $35,000 IN SALES.
ARE YOU IN CHEMISTRY?
WHAT'S
YOUR BACKGROUND?
NO, SO ACTUALLY NONE
OF US ARE CHEMISTS.
I'M A MECHANICAL ENGINEER
BY BACKGROUND.
WHEN DES CAME TO ME WITH THIS
PROBLEM, I SAID, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK I CAN FIGURE THIS OUT."
I'VE GOT A FEW PATENTS
FROM MY TIME WORKING
AT JOHNSON & JOHNSON DOING
MEDICAL DEVICE DEVELOPMENT.
I'M A PROBLEM SOLVER.
I LIKE HOW YOU
JUST THREW THAT IN.
John: WAIT A MINUTE.
I LIKE HOW YOU
JUST THREW THAT IN.
WAS THIS DEVELOPED WHILE
YOU WERE WORKING THERE?
NO, THIS WAS DEVELOPED WHILE
WE WERE IN BUSINESS SCHOOL.
WHICH SCHOOL?
-HARVARD BUSINESS SCHOOL.
WHAT'S PROPRIETARY
IN IT?
THIS IS ACTUALLY NATIVE WOOL
THAT'S PULLED STRAIGHT
OFF OF A LAMB.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY ALL CURLY.
-PASS THAT TO KEVIN.
-HERE, KEVIN.
HE HASN'T FELT HAIR
FOR A LONG TIME.
PUT IT ON YOUR HEAD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-SO, YOU'RE --
-KEVIN, YOU CAN KEEP SOME.
SORRY, NATE,
I CUT YOU OFF.
SO, THERE'S ACTUALLY
A PROTEIN BOND
THAT KEEPS THOSE FIBERS
IN A CURLED CONFIGURATION.
WHEN YOU TAKE YOUR SWEATER
AND YOU THROW IT
IN THE WASHER AND DRYER,
IT ACTUALLY BREAKS THOSE BONDS.
THE HOT WATER
AND THE AGITATION BREAKS IT
AND ALLOWS YOUR SWEATER
TO CURL BACK UP.
SO, OUR CHEMISTRY IS
THAT OUR PRODUCT ACTUALLY BREAKS
THAT BOND CHEMICALLY
AND ALLOWS YOU
TO RE-SHAPE YOUR SWEATER.
THE CHEMICAL IS ACTUALLY
A FAIRLY COMMON COMPOUND,
BUT IT HAS NEVER BEEN USED
AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANYTHING
THAT'S BEEN USED
TO UNSHRINK WOOL.
SO, WE'VE PATENTED
THE METHOD AND USE.
Greiner: BUT THE THING IS
IF YOU BUY A WOOL ITEM...
YES.
...AND YOU CARE FOR IT PROPERLY,
YOU WOULDN'T NEED TO --
-NO, IT STILL SHRINKS.
-RIGHT.
AND GOD BLESS YOU IF YOU DO.
WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT --
O'Leary:
SO, YOU'RE SAYING PEOPLE
MAKE THE MISTAKE ENOUGH
THAT A BIG MARKET EXISTS
FOR THIS SOLUTION?
45% OF AMERICANS ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THIS EACH YEAR.
John: HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
A LOT OF THE WOOL
BEING BOUGHT AND PROCESSED
WILL NOT SHRINK IN THE WAY
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
SO THE 40% YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS REALLY ABOUT 12%.
HOW -- HOW LARGE
DO YOU THINK THE MARKET IS?
GIVE ME A DOLLAR AMOUNT.
-YES.
-$200 MILLION.
-$200 MILLION?
AND TELL ME ABOUT THE $200
MILLION AND HOW YOU GET IT.
ALL RIGHT, SO TWO THINGS.
THE FIRST THING IS
THAT WE DON'T NECESSARILY
SEE THIS AS A REACTIVE PRODUCT,
IN WHICH YOU PURCHASE IT
ONLY BECAUSE YOU MAKE A MISTAKE.
AS FAR AS WE'RE CONCERNED,
THIS SHOULD BE SOMETHING
AKIN TO ASPIRIN.
YOU SHOULD ALWAYS BE
THINKING THIS IS
IN YOUR CLOSET
OR YOUR LAUNDRY ROOM.
IN TERMS OF PROJECTIONS,
WE'RE LOOKING AT $130,000
THIS UPCOMING YEAR.
YOU BELIEVE YOU'LL DO
$130,000 THIS YEAR? OKAY.
YES, YES, 20,000 UNITS.
RIGHT.
OKAY, SO HERE'S
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, BUT WHERE
IS IT GOING TO THE $135,000?
-MARK.
-WHAT ABOUT THE RETAIL?
WHERE IS -- YOU'RE TELLING US
WHERE IT'S GOING NOW.
FOR THIS UPCOMING -- RIGHT.
WE HAD RETAILERS
THAT WERE READY FOR US
AS EARLY AS SEPTEMBER,
BUT WE WEREN'T READY FOR THAT.
WHAT KIND OF RETAILERS
WERE READY FOR YOU?
SO, WE'RE LOOKING
AT JO-ANN FABRICS,
WE'RE LOOKING AT MACY'S,
LOOKING AT J.C. PENNEY --
LOOKING AT?
ARE YOU LOOKING AT THEM
OR ARE THEY LOOKING AT YOU?
IT'S A COMBINATION OF BOTH.
SO WHEN WE LAUNCHED, WE ACTUALLY
HAD A LOT OF OUTREACH
FROM RETAILERS, AND WE SAID,
"LOOK, WE'RE NOT READY YET.
WE DON'T HAVE THE INVENTORY."
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT,
SO HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
SO, WE RETAIL $12 TO $15.
-WHOA.
-WE MAKE IT FOR ABOUT $1.
WHY ARE YOU SELLING IT
FOR $12 TO $15?
Stolar:
SO, WHEN WE FIRST LAUNCHED,
WE WERE ACTUALLY SELLING IT
FOR $9.99,
AND WE THOUGHT THAT WAS FAIR
GIVEN THAT THE AVERAGE RANGE
OF PRICE
ON THE LAUNDRY AISLE
WAS ANYWHERE
FROM ABOUT $4 TO ABOUT $12.
SO, THEN WE STARTED
TO GET FEEDBACK FROM PEOPLE,
AND THEY WOULD SAY,
"OH, MY GOSH,
I CANNOT BELIEVE
YOU JUST SAVED THIS.
I WOULD'VE PAID THREE TIMES
AS MUCH.
I'VE BEEN WAITING TO SAVE
THIS CASHMERE SWEATER.
IT'S BEEN
IN THE BACK OF MY CLOSET.
YOU'RE UNDER-VALUING
YOUR PRODUCT."
THEN WE HEARD FROM INVESTORS,
AND THEY SAID,
"WE REALLY THINK
YOU SHOULD BE CHARGING MORE."
THERE'S AN EMOTIONAL CONNECTION
WITH A LOT OF WOOL GARMENTS,
AND A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO SAVE,
THEY HAVE --
THEY'RE BELOVED TO THEM.
NATE, WOULD YOU CALL THIS A
PRODUCT OR A BUSINESS RIGHT NOW?
IT'S RIGHT ON THE CUSP,
I WOULD SAY.
OKAY, IF THIS IS
REALLY TURNING INTO A BUSINESS,
WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS THE CEO?
-OH, I LIKE THAT.
-WOW, THAT WAS GOOD.
TO ME,
THE BEST THINGS ARE
WHEN YOU HAVE A SOLUTION
TO A PROBLEM.
BUT THE PROBLEM FOR ME IS --
IS I THINK
YOU HAVE A VERY,
VERY LIMITED MARKET.
I DON'T THINK THAT WOOL
AND WOOL PRODUCTS ARE
THAT COMMONLY BOUGHT.
NOT LIKE COTTON PRODUCTS.
THEN A PERSON HAS TO HAVE SHRUNK
IT TO THEN NEED YOUR PRODUCT,
SO NOW THAT MAKES YOU
EVEN SMALLER.
I DON'T SEE THIS
SCALING UP REALLY HUGE.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
NATE, I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
I THINK
THAT THE TARGET MARKET
IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON A RELATIVELY LIMITED BUDGET.
HOW BIG DID YOU SAY
THIS CAN BE IN A YEAR OR TWO?
WE BELIEVE, IN TWO YEARS,
WE CAN HAVE $1.5 MILLION
IN SALES.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $150,000
FOR 33.3%.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S WORTH,
BUT I LIKE IT.
I LIKE THE IDEA.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
UM, THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE EQUITY
THAN WE WERE INTERESTED IN --
YEAH, THAT HAPPENS SOMETIMES
IN THE SHARK TANK.
HOW MUCH EQUITY
WERE YOU INTERESTED IN...
UH, SO, I MEAN, I WOULD COUNTER
FOR $150,000 FOR 15%.
WHY WOULD I DO THAT?
THERE'S NO OTHER OFFER.
CERTAINLY YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT, NATE.
ROBERT, MARK, DAYMOND?
♪♪
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
NATE AND DES HAVE ONE OFFER
ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR WOOL SHRINKAGE
SOLUTION UNSHRINKIT.
THERE'S NO OTHER OFFER.
ROBERT, MARK, DAYMOND?
John:
WE NEVER HAD A PROBLEM
AT FUBU WITH SHRINKAGE,
ACTUALLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH, UM...
MY THING IS THAT I DON'T WANT
TO GROW THIS BUSINESS.
I'M INTERESTED
IN LICENSING THIS.
I WOULD LOVE TO TAKE 25%
OF THIS FOR 150K
CONTINGENT ON US GOING
AND GETTING A LICENSE.
SO, THAT'S MY DEAL,
'CAUSE I DO NOT KNOW HOW
TO EDUCATE THE WORLD ON THIS.
Stolar: SURE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF THEY KNOW IT'S NEEDED.
SO, HE DOESN'T THINK
YOU CAN BUILD A BRAND
IS WHAT HE'S SAYING.
GUYS, OBVIOUSLY
I'M NOT A CLOTHES GUY.
BUT YOU'RE SMART.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU OBVIOUSLY
THOUGHT THIS THROUGH.
SO, I'LL DO THE 150K
FOR 15%.
GOT A DEAL?
-DES?
-YES.
-THINK WE GOT A DEAL.
-DONE.
-MARK.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MARK.
I REALLY CAN'T WAIT TO WORK
WITH YOU.
-OH, IT'LL BE A LOT OF FUN.
-PITTSBURGH GUY.
MARK, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
DES, YES!
SO, YOU'RE NOT EVEN
CONSIDERING MY OFFER?
-I'M SORRY, DAYMOND.
-DAYMOND, I'M SORRY.
-MONEY BAGS.
-I'LL GO DOWN TO 30%.
Stolar: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE GUIDANCE.
-GOOD LUCK.
-DES. YES!
-I THOUGHT MARK WAS GOING OUT.
-I DID, TOO.
AND THEN HE GAVE US THE OFFER.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOSH."
LIKE, THIS IS IT.
HE GAVE US WHAT I ASKED FOR.
I MEAN, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THIS IS FANTASTIC.
-WE'RE HERE. WE'RE DONE.
-WE'RE DONE.
-CHECK IT OUT.
-AMAZING.
CONGRATS, D.J.
YOU EXCITED?
I AM PSYCHED.
"SHARK TANK"
IS BACK AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
TODAY, WE'RE HERE FOR A GLOBAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP EVENT
HIGHLIGHTING MILLENNIAL
ENTREPRENEURS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
WE'RE ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT
OUR VERY OWN DAYMOND JOHN
AS HE'S NAMED FOR
THE PRESIDENTIAL AMBASSADOR
FOR GLOBAL ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
Man: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WELCOME TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE A LOT
OF BRAIN POWER HERE.
WE'VE GOT INNOVATORS
AND INVESTORS.
WE'VE EVEN GOT A FEW SHARKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MARK AND DAYMOND AND BARBARA.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO START A NEW BUSINESS
OR A NEW SOCIAL VENTURE.
I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE
THAT AMERICA'S BUSINESS LEADERS
AND INNOVATORS ARE JOINING US
IN THIS EFFORT.
SO, I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF OUR GLOBAL ENTREPRENEURSHIP
AMBASSADORS.
CAN YOU GUYS ALL STAND UP?
I WANT TO JUST GIVE THEM
A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE,
'CAUSE THEY'RE DOING
REALLY IMPORTANT WORK.
PRESIDENT OBAMA ESTABLISHED
A PAGE PROGRAM IN 2014.
THE GOAL IS TO UTILIZE
OUR NETWORK, SKILLS,
AND RESOURCES
TO INFLUENCE
THE NEXT GENERATION
OF GLOBAL ENTREPRENEURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYBODY.
I WOULD'VE NEVER THOUGHT
THIS OPPORTUNITY WAS POSSIBLE
WHEN I WAS JUST A KID
WITH A DREAM.
NOW I'M ACTUALLY WORKING
WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
I AM AMAZED AND HONORED.
Contreras-Sweet: THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE FUTURE
OF OUR GLOBAL ECONOMY,
AND, TODAY, WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT THE BUSINESSES
THEY'RE BUILDING.
FREEping ALLOWS ANYONE
IN THE WORLD WITH A MOBILE PHONE
TO ACCESS INFORMATION FOR FREE.
Man: FGC PLASMA SOLUTIONS
USES PLASMA
TO MAKE FLYING SAFER
AND MORE EFFICIENT.
WE WORK TO CONNECT WOMEN
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
TO THE LIFE-SAVING SUPPLIES
THEY NEED AT CHILDBIRTH.
I'VE LEARNED
BY INVESTING IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS
ON "SHARK TANK."
THE REALLY GOOD ONES ARE ALWAYS
GOOD WHEN THE CHIPS ARE DOWN.
IDEAS ARE EASY.
WHAT'S HARD IS DOING THE WORK.
THESE YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS
HAVE THE CREATIVITY,
THE IMAGINATION
TO REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THE FUTURE SUCCESS
OF THE WORLD ECONOMY
RESTS ON THEIR SHOULDERS.
WE HAVE TO DO ALL WE CAN
TO SUPPORT THEM.
GIVE IT UP
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE PANEL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TELL HIM I SAID HELLO.
John: VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
FULLY BEHIND THIS INITIATIVE.
HE HAS A PASSION, AS WELL,
FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP,
AND IT'S REALLY A PLEASURE
TO MEET HIM AND WORK WITH HIM.
FIRST OF ALL, THANKS
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AND I JUST CAME BY
TO SAY KEEP IT UP.
"SHARK TANK" HAS BECOME
AN AMERICAN PHENOMENON.
AND US BEING HERE,
THE SUPPORT OF THE PRESIDENT
JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU THAT
THE AMERICAN DREAM IS
ALIVE AND WELL.
AND I THINK "SHARK TANK"
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH THAT.
♪♪
[ ENGINE TURNS OVER ]
MY NAME IS BRYCE HUDSON, AND
I LIVE IN MURRIETA, CALIFORNIA.
I STARTED RIDING MOTORCYCLES
WHEN I WAS ABOUT 13 YEARS OLD.
I WAS KIND OF ALWAYS
THE HOTSHOT KID
THAT WOULD DO THE JUMPS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
NOW I'M A PROFESSIONAL
FREESTYLE MOTOCROSS RIDER
AND I COMPETE IN THE X GAMES.
THE X GAMES IS BASICALLY
THE OLYMPICS FOR ACTION SPORTS.
I COMPETE IN MOTO X STEP UP,
WHICH IS BASICALLY
POLE VAULTING ON A MOTORCYCLE.
SO YOU HAVE TO JUMP UP
AND OVER A HIGH BAR.
IF YOU CLIP IT,
YOU'RE ELIMINATED.
IF YOU'RE THE LAST MAN STANDING,
YOU WIN.
I'VE BEEN COMPETING SINCE 2013,
AND SINCE THEN,
I'VE WON ONE GOLD MEDAL
AND TWO SILVER MEDALS.
I DECIDED TO START A BUSINESS
'CAUSE I'M ALWAYS WORKING
ON MY BIKES,
GETTING DIRTY AND WHATNOT,
AND IT WAS REALLY A PRODUCT
THAT I NEEDED.
I TAUGHT MYSELF
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT
FROM THE FORMULATION
TO PACKAGING.
I'VE DONE IT ALL RIGHT HERE
IN MY GARAGE.
I'M ONLY 25 YEARS OLD
AND I'VE SUSTAINED
A LOT OF HEAVY INJURIES,
AND I KNOW
I CAN'T DO THIS FOREVER,
SO I SEE THIS COMPANY
AS MY FUTURE.
I REALLY HOPE MY PRODUCT GOES
IN THERE,
GETS THEM INTERESTED,
AND GETS THEM ALL REVVED UP.
[ ENGINE REVVING ]
-WHOA.
-WOW.
Greiner: HOLY MOLY.
[ ENGINE STOPS ]
-PHEW, PHEW.
-VERY COOL.
HELLO, SHARKS,
MY NAME IS BRYCE HUDSON.
I'M FROM MURRIETA, CALIFORNIA,
AND MY COMPANY IS GRIP CLEAN.
I'M SEEKING $85,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
NOW, SHARKS, I KNOW DIRT.
WHETHER I'M OUT COMPETING
ON MY MOTORCYCLE
IN THE X GAMES,
TRYING TO WIN MORE MEDALS
TO ADD MORE MEDALS TO ADD
TO MY COLLECTION,
OR WHETHER I'M IN THE GARAGE
WORKING ON MY MOTORCYCLE,
I'M ALWAYS AROUND DIRT,
GREASE, AND GRIME.
AND THROUGHOUT THE YEARS,
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE PRODUCT
TO THOROUGHLY CLEANSE MY HANDS.
SO, I CAME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE DIRT
TO FIGHT DIRT.
YES, THAT'S RIGHT --
DIRT JUST LIKE THE KIND
YOU WOULD FIND OUTSIDE.
SO, YOU'RE PROBABLY
ASKING YOURSELF
WHY WOULD YOU PUT DIRT IN SOAP?
SOUNDS KIND OF CRAZY.
TURNS OUT THAT DIRT
IS ACTUALLY THE BEST SUBSTANCE
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD
AT ABSORBING GREASE, OILS,
CHEMICALS, AND TOXINS.
BUT ON TOP OF THAT,
IT REALLY ACTS AS AN EXFOLIANT
TOWARDS YOUR SKIN.
SO, WHERE GREASE WOULD NORMALLY
REMAIN DEEP IN THE PORES
OF YOUR HANDS,
IT'S ABLE TO REALLY GO IN THERE,
LATCH AND HOLD ON
TO THAT GREASE AND RINSE CLEAN.
GRIP CLEAN IS PERFECT
FOR AUTOMOTIVE MECHANICS,
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS,
FARMERS, LANDSCAPERS,
OR SIMPLY ANYBODY WHO GETS DIRTY
AND NEEDS TO GET CLEAN.
SO, I CREATED THIS IN MY GARAGE,
AND SEVERAL MONTHS LATER,
AND TWO VERY CLEAN HANDS LATER,
I FEEL MY PRODUCT IS UNIQUE
AND A WINNER.
SO, SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO GET CLEAN
BY GETTING DIRTY
WITH GRIP CLEAN?
BRYCE,
YOU WENT TO THE X GAMES?
I DID, YES, I HAVE --
WHAT DID YOU WIN?
ARE THOSE MEDALS?
YEAH, OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS,
I'VE ACQUIRED THREE MEDALS.
AND WHAT EVENT
ARE YOU IN?
STEP UP -- MOTOCROSS HIGH JUMP,
BASICALLY POLE VAULTING
ON A MOTORCYCLE.
-YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL, HUH?
-WOW.
-REAL DEAL.
-YOU EVER HURT YOURSELF BAD?
YEAH, THAT'S KIND OF WHY I'M
TRYING TO START A COMPANY HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOU
AND, LIKE,
A LAVA OR A GOOP?
VERY GOOD QUESTION.
IS IT JUST
THE ALL-NATURAL ELEMENT?
YES,
THE ALL-NATURAL ASPECT.
MOST MECHANICS ARE WASHING
MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY.
THEIR HANDS WILL BREAK OUT
IN A RASH.
SO, WHEN YOU'RE WORKING
WITH CHEMICALS ALL DAY,
THE LAST THING YOU WANT TO USE
IS ANOTHER
CHEMICALLY INFUSED SOAP
TO TAKE THOSE CHEMICALS OFF.
THE DIRT THAT'S ACTUALLY
IN THERE,
IT'S ALL COSMETIC-GRADE CLAY.
-OKAY, WHAT ELSE IS IN IT?
SO, IT'S A COCONUT OIL
AND OLIVE OIL BASED HAND SOAP.
AND THEN YOU ADD THE CLAY
TO BE THE EXFOLIANT
TO HELP GET ALL THE GREASE.
-CORRECT.
-CAN I TRY IT?
-I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO TRY IT.
I CAME A LONG WAY, SO I'D LOVE
FOR YOU TO TRY IT.
IS THIS DIRT?
YES, IT IS.
-"IS THIS DIRT?"
-IS THIS DIRT?
WELL, IS THIS YOUR DIRT?
IS THIS WHAT'S --
IS THAT WHAT'S IN IT?
THAT IS THE EXACT STUFF
THAT I PUT IN IT.
JUST USE IT
AS YOU WOULD A REGULAR SOAP.
WATER ACTIVATED.
SO, I LIKE TO SCRUB IT
ON MY HANDS QUITE A BIT.
-OH, IT'S REALLY THICK.
-YEAH, IT IS.
'CAUSE ANOTHER COMPLAINT
THAT I HAD
WITH A LOT OF THE OTHER SOAPS
IS THEY WERE REALLY ABRASIVE,
SO IF YOU WERE USING IT
MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY,
IT'D REALLY EAT YOUR HANDS UP.
-SO I TRIED TO MAKE --
-OH, WOW.
-IT TRULY WORKS, AND --
-OH, MY GOSH.
HONESTLY, SURPRISINGLY,
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
DID YOU GET ANY RETAIL
DISTRIBUTION ON THIS?
I HAVEN'T.
I'M A PRE-REVENUE COMPANY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DISTRIBUTION
CHANNELS SET UP NOW?
YES, I HAVE ABOUT
FIVE LOCAL MOTORCYCLE SHOPS
THAT ARE READY
TO SELL IT RIGHT NOW.
WHAT PRICE POINT
ARE YOU GONNA SELL IT AT?
WHAT -- WHAT DOES IT
COST YOU TO MAKE IT?
COSTS ME $2.12 TO MAKE
THE BOTTLE, PACKAGE,
DONE, EVERYTHING.
WHOLESALE IT AT $5,
RETAIL AT STORES FOR $8.99.
AND WHAT'S YOUR
COMPETITOR SELL FOR?
COMPETITORS RETAIL
FROM ANYWHERE FROM $5 TO $8
DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY'RE SELLING.
SO, THIS IS EXPENSIVE
FOR YOU TO MAKE.
IT IS. YES, IT IS.
THE MORE I CAN PRODUCE
OF THIS, OBVIOUSLY,
MY MARGINS ARE GONNA BE
BETTER AND BETTER.
RIGHT, HOW LOW
CAN YOU GET THE COST?
I FEEL THAT ANYTHING
OVER 5,000 UNITS,
I CAN GET IT DOWN TO $1.80,
AND THEN PUSHING
ANYTHING OVER 10,000,
I FEEL I CAN GET IT DOWN
TO $1.25.
SO, 10,000 UNITS,
YOUR WHOLESALE IS 5 BUCKS.
-MM-HMM.
-THAT'S ONLY $50,000 IN SALES.
-THAT'S NOT A BUSINESS.
IF YOU PLANNED OUT A WAY
THAT YOU CAN GET
TO 100,000 UNITS
IN SALES PER YEAR,
AND THEN WHAT WOULD
YOUR COSTS BE?
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
YES, I HAVE PLANNED IT OUT.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY,
I WANT TO MAKE
MORE BOTTLES UP
TO THE $100,000 RANGE.
BUT YOU GOT
TO KNOW THE NUMBERS.
TO BREAK A DOLLAR
FOR COST OF GOODS,
HOW MANY UNITS
DO YOU HAVE TO ORDER?
I WOULD HAVE
TO ORDER 20,000 UNITS.
-20,000 UNITS.
-THAT'S IT?
-YES.
-TO GET UNDER A DOLLAR.
YES.
Herjavec: BRYCE,
IN SEASON ONE, BARBARA AND I
DID A DEAL WITH A PRODUCT
CALLED GREASE MONKEY.
-YEAH, I'M FAMILIAR WITH IT.
-I REMEMBER THAT.
I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU REMEMBER THAT.
I REMEMBER WATCHING THAT.
AND WHAT IT WAS -- IT WAS
A VERY NATURAL PRODUCT
THAT CLEANED OIL.
-WORKED GREAT.
-MM-HMM.
I THOUGHT PEOPLE WOULD LOOK
AT THIS IN STORES AND SAY,
"OH, MY GOSH, HERE'S A CHEMICAL
ONE, HERE'S A NATURAL ONE.
LET ME BUY THE NATURAL."
BUT WE FOUND THAT CONSUMERS
DIDN'T CARE ENOUGH.
-HMM.
-YOU KNOW, LISTEN.
YOU KNOW, TO GO OUT THERE
AND WIN THOSE AWARDS,
I'M SURE THAT YOU ARE
SOUGHT AFTER
IN YOUR MARKET
FOR VARIOUS THINGS.
YOU MAY HAVE
A GREAT MACHINE BEHIND YOU.
I MEAN, YOU COULD BE TONY HAWK
OF THIS AREA.
I REALLY WANT TO TARGET
THE MOTORCYCLE INDUSTRY
IN A SENSE BECAUSE I HAVE
A CREDIBLE NAME IN THAT ASPECT.
-ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY.
-AS YOU SHOULD.
SO, IF YOU'RE GOOD AT SOMETHING,
GO FULL FORCE WITH THAT.
YEP, YEAH.
SO, I HAVE A TEAM
OF FRIENDS BEHIND ME.
ARE YOU MAKING IT -- ARE YOU
MANUFACTURING IT AT HOME?
ARE YOU DOMESTICALLY --
YES, OUT OF MY GARAGE
RIGHT NOW.
OUT OF YOUR GARAGE?
YEAH, THAT'S THE PROBLEM
IS I'M MAKING IT
OUT OF A FIVE-GALLON BUCKET
RIGHT NOW.
-YOU REALLY ARE?
-I TRULY AM, AND THAT'S WHY --
THAT'S AWESOME.
GOOD FOR YOU, BABY.
I MEAN, I CAN'T SELL IT
TO THE BIGGER SHOPS
BECAUSE IT'LL TAKE ME
10 YEARS TO MAKE 100 BOTTLES.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING ELSE.
HAVE YOU TRIED SOCIAL MEDIA?
IT'S NOT REALLY WORKING OUT,
AND I'LL EXPLAIN WHY.
IT'S BECAUSE NO ONE REALLY WANTS
TO BUY THIS PRODUCT ONLINE.
THEY WANT TO GO
TO HOME DEPOT...
THAT'S TRUE.
...WHEN THEY'RE BUYING ALL
THEIR SUPPLIES AND EVERYTHING.
-THEY WANT IT FASTER.
-YEAH, THEY WANT IT NOW.
LOOK, I ADMIRE ANYBODY
WHO'S AN ATHLETE.
I MEAN, IT TAKES AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF DISCIPLINE TO DO THIS.
I CAN SENSE
YOU'RE GOING OUT HERE, ROBERT.
WELL, I'VE BEEN DOWN
THIS ROAD WITH GREASE MONKEY,
AND WHAT I LEARNED OUT OF IT IS,
YOU KNOW, AS MARK ALWAYS SAYS,
IT'S A HARD WAY TO GRIND
YOUR WAY TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
AND MAYBE I KNOW TOO MUCH.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY WHY
DID YOU GET IN YOUR BUSINESS?
I'M LIKE I'M GLAD
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I KNOW NOW...
RIGHT.
...'CAUSE I WOULD'VE
NEVER GOT INTO IT.
IN THIS CASE,
MAYBE I KNOW TOO MUCH.
I'M -- I'M OUT.
STILL FOUR SHARKS LEFT.
-GOT IT.
I RESPECT THAT.
-YEAH.
BRYCE, LOOK, YOU'RE DOING
A LOT OF GREAT THINGS,
BUT YOU'RE NOT
A COMPANY YET.
Y-YOU'VE GOT THE DESIRE,
YOU'VE GOT THE EFFORT,
BUT YOU -- YOU DON'T HAVE
THE REST OF IT, RIGHT?
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW
TO MAKE IT A BUSINESS YET,
AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT.
YEAH.
I --
YEAH, IT'S A BUMMER
'CAUSE I KNEW COMING INTO THIS,
I WAS AT A BIG DISADVANTAGE
BEING A PREMATURE COMPANY,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT
TO HIDE THE FACT,
DIDN'T TRY TO MAKE IT
ALL GLITZ AND GLAMOUR --
THAT I'M SOMETHING BIGGER
THAN I'M NOT.
I JUST THINK IT'S GONNA BE
TOO MUCH WORK
FROM OUR POST RELATIVE
TO THE UPSIDE,
SO UNFORTUNATELY,
FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU.
I, UH --
I LIKE THE IDEA.
I THINK THIS IS ONLINE,
AND I THINK THAT YOU SAID
YOU CAN GET THE BOTTLES DOWN
TO A DOLLAR WITH 20,000 UNITS.
YES, SIR.
I THINK YOU NEED
JUST $20,000 THEN FOR --
AND THAT YOU
CAN RAISE $20,000
AND YOU CAN PUT THESE THINGS
ONLINE WITH YOUR GANG.
YOU KNOW, SET UP SMALL BOOTHS
AT THE SHOWS,
AND I THINK THAT YOU COULD PUT
A LOT OF MONEY IN YOUR POCKET
WITHOUT THE PROBLEM
OF HAVING AN INVESTOR.
RIGHT.
I CAN'T BE OF ANY SERVICE
TO YOU, AND I THINK YOU COULD BE
OF MORE SERVICE TO YOURSELF,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
KEVIN, I'D LOVE TO HEAR
YOUR ADVICE ON THIS PRODUCT.
YEAH, LOOK, I'M --
I'M IN THE CAMP THAT SAYS
YOU'RE VERY CREDIBLE
AND YOU BUILT IT OUT OF A NEED
THAT YOU HAD YOURSELF, WHICH IS
WHERE GREAT PRODUCTS COME FROM.
HAVE YOU DONE ANY WORK
IN FIGURING OUT
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA
MANUFACTURE IT,
WHO'S GONNA ACTUALLY FORMULATE
IT FOR YOU IN LARGE VOLUMES?
I STILL WANT TO DO
IT MYSELF, AND THAT'S
WHAT THE INVESTMENT IS FOR.
'CAUSE, LIKE I SAID, I'M DOING
IT IN A BUCKET RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S NOT PRACTICAL, SO --
WHEN YOU SAY DO IT YOURSELF,
ARE YOU SAYING
YOU WANT TO KEEP
MANUFACTURING IT YOURSELF?
I WOULD LIKE
TO KEEP DOING IT MYSELF,
BUT I AM NOT AGAINST
SOMEBODY ELSE DOING IT.
-IN YOUR HOUSE?
-YOU HAVE TO.
YOU CAN'T DO THE VOLUME.
-YOU GOT TO, BRYCE.
Cuban: YOU GOT TO.
YEAH, WHY -- WHY WOULD YOU
BUILD IT ON YOUR OWN?
YEAH.
I TRIED --
I USED EVERY CREDIBLE SOURCE
THAT I HAD ABOUT A YEAR AGO
TRYING TO FIND MANUFACTURERS
TO MAKE THIS FOR ME.
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU TRIED
TO FIND MANUFACTURERS?
WELL, WHEN I SAID, "HEY, I WANT
TO PUT DIRT AS AN ACTIVE
INGREDIENT,"
SAID, "HEY, WE DON'T WANT
DIRT IN OUR SHOP
CONTAMINATING
ANYTHING WE'VE HAD."
OKAY, SO THAT WAS
OUT OF THE QUESTION.
CONTAMINATING WHAT?
SO, BRYCE,
THAT'S NOT GOOD NEWS.
Cuban: YEAH.
BECAUSE YOU --
IN ORDER TO DO THIS
AND ACTUALLY GO
TO A LARGE DISTRIBUTOR
OR A BIG-BOX PLAYER THAT'S GONNA
ORDER 100,000 UNITS...
MM-HMM.
...YOU CAN'T DO IT
IN YOUR GARAGE.
I MEAN, IT'S NOT AS HARD
OF A PROCESS
AS YOU WOULD THINK
TO MANUFACTURE IT.
ALL I REALLY NEED THE MONEY FOR
IS 55-GALLON DRUMS
AND A MIXING HEAD.
I HAVE ALL THE INGREDIENTS,
I THROW IT IN THERE --
NO, MAN.
BUT THEN YOU'VE GOT
TO BOTTLE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BOTTLE EACH ONE,
YOU'VE GOT TO LABEL EACH ONE.
IF YOU START SELLING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF UNITS --
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE, IN A SENSE. I GET IT.
YOU KNOW, BRYCE,
I LISTEN TO THIS STORY.
I JUST DON'T SEE ENOUGH MEAT
ON THE BONE TO INVEST IN.
GOOD LUCK.
I'M OUT.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT NOBODY
WILL MANUFACTURE IT FOR YOU,
THAT'S VERY CONCERNING
TO ME BECAUSE PEOPLE
WOULD LOVE TO MANUFACTURE
A NEW PRODUCT
IF YOU'RE
GONNA PAY THEM.
OF COURSE.
SO, WHY IS IT THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO MANUFACTURE?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH IT?
YOU KNOW, THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
THAT I REALLY HAD
WAS I DIDN'T FEEL PEOPLE
TOOK ME SERIOUSLY.
I -- I MEAN, I SET UP A COUPLE
MEETINGS WITH THESE PLANTS,
AND THEY'RE BIG,
MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR PLANTS
AND I WAS THIS KID COMING IN.
BUT I FEEL IF YOU KNEW
A MANUFACTURING PLANT
OR IF EVEN YOU SET
UP A MEETING WITH ME,
YOU BRING SO MUCH MORE
OF A CREDIBLE SOURCE THERE
THAT THEY COULD BE LIKE,
"ALL RIGHT,
LET-- LET'S DO THIS."
UM...
IT'S A TOUGH ONE, LORI.
IT FITS WITHIN MY FAMILY
OF PRODUCTS, YOU KNOW?
I MEAN, IT'S --
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
I LIKE THE FACT
THAT IT'S NATURAL.
I THINK PEOPLE CARE.
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF MEN
AND WOMEN,
THEIR HANDS ARE RIPPED RAW
WITH PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE...
VERY TRUE.
...BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
TOO STRONG OF SOAPS IN THEM.
MM-HMM.
SO, THIS IS A GREAT IDEA
AND A GREAT CONCEPT.
LOOK, I'LL TAKE A FLIER ON YOU.
-YEAH.
BUT HONESTLY,
YOU'RE GONNA NEED ME
TO REALLY RUN
THE WHOLE BUSINESS.
I MEAN,
I'M GONNA HAVE TO COME IN
AND HELP YOU TO GET
THIS OUT THERE EVERYWHERE,
WHICH I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT WE CAN DO.
BUT WE HAVE TO REVISE
YOUR PACKAGING, LABELING.
WE HAVE TO FIND YOU
A MANUFACTURER AND EVERYTHING.
SO, I'LL GIVE YOU THE $85,000,
BUT FOR 35%.
DEAL.
-OH, OKAY.
-BAM!
-DEAL. THAT'S IT.
-THERE YOU GO.
John: ALL RIGHT.
I'LL TAKE IT.
I WON'T MESS AROUND.
-ALL RIGHT, GOOD JOB.
-ALL RIGHT, WELL, GOOD.
I APPRECIATE IT.
WE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
LORI, GET ON THE BACK
OF THAT BIKE.
[ Laughing ] NO! NO.
O'Leary: YOU DID GREAT TODAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
[ SIGHS ]
THAT WAS CLOSE.
I'M SO THANKFUL LORI
TOOK A SHOT ON ME.
I MEAN, I'M A YOUNG ENTREPRENEUR
AND SHE WAS IN THE SAME POSITION
WHEN SHE WAS YOUNGER,
AND, UH, HOPEFULLY
I CAN PROVE HER RIGHT
AND, UH,
FOLLOW IN HER FOOTSTEPS.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A COMPANY THAT STRIVES
TO MAKE ALL YOUR VIDEOS
LOOK PROFESSIONAL.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JEFF OVERALL
FROM NEWPORT BEACH, CALIFORNIA.
SERIAL ENTREPRENEUR
AND FOUNDER OF POLAR PRO.
TODAY I AM SEEKING
A $500,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
-OH.
-YO, DUDE!
Herjavec: DUDE.
AT POLAR PRO, WE DESIGN
INNOVATIVE CAMERA ACCESSORIES
THAT MAKE IT EASIER THAN EVER
FOR PEOPLE WITH MOBILE PHONES,
ACTION CAMERAS, OR EVEN DRONES
TO DOCUMENT THEIR ADVENTURES.
OUT OF OUR EXTENSIVE
PRODUCT LINE,
OUR THREE MOST POPULAR ITEMS
ARE ONE -- THE POWER POLE.
THE WORLD'S FIRST
BATTERY-INTEGRATED SELFIE STICK
ALLOWING USERS
TO CHARGE THEIR CAMERA ALL DAY
AND CAPTURE SICK
ANGLES OF THEMSELVES.
YEW. YEE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
TWO -- THE POWER VAULT.
ANOTHER FIRST OF ITS KIND.
THE ONLY ACTION CAMERA CASE
WITH A BUILT-IN BATTERY DOCK
ALLOWING YOU TO CHARGE MULTIPLE
BATTERIES OR USB DEVICES
NO MATTER HOW FAR OFF THE GRID
YOUR ADVENTURE TAKES YOU.
[ Surfer voice ]
NICE!
THREE -- OUR NEW FILTER SETS
FOR DRONES ALLOW PILOTS
TO CAPTURE THE MOST VIBRANT,
CINEMATIC VIDEOS POSSIBLE,
AND ALSO PROTECT THE LENS
FOR WHEN YOU FLY
YOUR DRONE
INTO YOUR NEIGHBOR'S TREE.
NOW, ALL OF OUR PRODUCTS
ARE DESIGNED
BY OUR PASSION
FOR ADVENTURE AND FILMING,
AND WITH AN INVESTMENT
AND GUIDANCE
FROM ONE OF YOU SHARKS,
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HARNESS
THE HUGE AMOUNT OF DEMAND
FOR OUR PRODUCTS
AND HELP USERS EVERYWHERE
CAPTURE THE MOST EPIC CONTENT
POSSIBLE.
SO, WHO'S READY
TO WAX UP THEIR BOARD
AND RIDE
THIS TASTY WAVE WITH ME?
ARE THESE UNITS
CURRENTLY OUT ON THE MARKET?
YES, SO, WE HAVE 31 SKUs
LIVE ON THE MARKET RIGHT NOW.
-31 SKUs?
-JEFF, DO YOU MAKE THEM?
Herjavec: ARE YOU
MANUFACTURING THESE?
WE DESIGN, WE MANUFACTURE,
WE ASSEMBLE,
WE MARKET, WE DO EVERYTHING.
WHAT'S YOUR
BIGGEST-SELLING ITEM?
RIGHT NOW, OUR CAMERA FILTERS
FOR THE DRONES
HAVE BEEN OUTSELLING --
REALLY?
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING?
Cuban: YEAH, 'CAUSE NOBODY ELSE
REALLY OUT THERE
WITH ADD-ONS
FOR DRONES YET.
-EXACTLY.
-WHAT DOES THAT SELL FOR?
THE THREE PACK IS $69.99.
WE ALSO HAVE A SIX PACK
THAT IS $149.99.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE THAT LANDED?
LANDED, IT'S $12.
OUR MARGINS RIGHT NOW
IS 75% TO 300%.
WOW!
John: I DO KNOW
THAT DRONES ARE BIG.
WHAT DOES THE FILTER DO?
SO, WE'VE GOT
A POLARIZER FILTER
AS WELL
AS NEUTRAL DENSITY FILTERS.
SO, WE'VE GOT A PRETTY SICK
COMPARISON VIDEO UP HERE.
I'M DYING
TO SEE YOUR JAM, BRO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
Greiner: WOW.
IS THAT THE DIFFERENCE
WE'RE LOOKING --
THE RIGHT HAS A FILTER ON?
-WELL, FILTER VERSUS NON-FILTER.
-THAT IS CORRECT.
-IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THAT IS AMAZING.
♪♪
Herjavec: COOL.
JEFF, WHAT ARE
YOUR TOTAL SALES?
IN 2011, THE FIRST YEAR
WE WERE IN BUSINESS,
WE DID $8,000.
-GNARLY, DUDE.
-YEE-HAW!
[ LAUGHS ]
LAST YEAR, WE DID $2.8 MILLION.
-WOW.
AND THIS YEAR, WE'RE ON TRACK
TO DO ABOUT $5.6 MILLION.
-WOW.
-YEAH!
-VERY IMPRESSIVE.
-NOW -- NOW THAT'S AMAZING.
THOSE ARE HUGE NUMBERS.
TELL US WHY
YOU RAMPED UP LIKE THAT.
WHAT WE DO WITH THOSE PROFITS
IS WE RE-INVEST IN R&D
AND MAKING OTHER ACCESSORIES
THAT OTHER PEOPLE AREN'T DOING.
I MEAN, WE'RE YOUNG,
WE'RE INNOVATIVE.
BY THE TIME SOMEBODY COMES IN
AND COPIES ONE OF OUR PRODUCTS,
WE'VE TAKEN PROFITS
AND MADE THREE OTHER ONES
AND KEEP IT GOING.
YOU'RE ALWAYS AHEAD
OF THE TREND.
-EXACTLY.
-AND, JEFF, ARE YOU A DESIGNER?
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUND?
SO, I'M AN ENTREPRENEUR
AT HEART.
WHEN I WAS 15 YEARS OLD,
I STARTED MY FIRST COMPANY --
WE GOT CRABS.
I WAS IN A FISH STORE AND I SAW
THAT THEY WERE SELLING
HERMIT CRABS FOR $4 EACH.
AND I WAS LIKE, "THESE CRABS
ARE DOWN AT THE BEACH.
LIKE,
THERE'S THOUSANDS OF THEM."
SO I WENT DOWN TO THE BEACH
WITH MY BUCKET,
THREW -- THREW A BUNCH OF CRABS
IN THE BUCKET,
AND STARTED SELLING
THEM ONLINE.
BUT WHEN WAS THAT?
HOW LONG AGO WAS THAT?
NO, WHEN?
THAT WAS 15, SO I'M 26 NOW.
SO, IT WAS ABOUT 11 YEARS AGO.
-OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
SO, HOW DID YOU
START THIS BUSINESS?
YEAH, SO THIS BUSINESS
WAS STARTED
WHEN I WAS
AT U.C. SANTA BARBARA.
I WAS ON THE SKI TEAM,
AND WE WERE FILMING A TON
ON THE SNOW WITH THESE CAMERAS,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"WHY DON'T MY VIDEOS LOOK
LIKE ALL THESE
PRODUCTION SKI MOVIES?"
SO I WENT ONLINE,
DID A LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH,
AND SAW THAT
ALL THESE GUYS' PRODUCTION
ARE USING POLARIZER FILTERS.
SO I WAS LIKE,
"OH, THAT'S COOL."
SO I WAS LIKE, "ALL RIGHT,
I'LL JUST BUY A DSLR1."
BOUGHT IT, DUCT TAPED IT
ONTO THE CAMERA,
WENT OUT THERE, AND I WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD!"
LIKE, THIS MAKES
A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
AND WAS LIKE, "HEY, I BET PEOPLE
WOULD PAY FOR THESE."
-WOW.
-SO I WENT HOME,
LEARNED HOW TO BUILD
THE WEBSITE, BUILT IT,
LEARNED HOW TO DO SOME S.E.O.,
OPTIMIZED IT, AND...
-AND HERE YOU ARE. BOOM.
-...STARTED POLAR PRO.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY'S
IN HERE, OR ARE THERE INVESTORS?
I USED $2,000
OF MY STUDENT LOAN MONEY, SO...
GOT IT.
...INSTEAD OF BUYING
TEXTBOOKS AND FOOD,
PRETTY MUCH, I USED IT
TO START THE COMPANY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I DID
WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL.
GOOD FOR YOU.
DO YOU HAVE DEBT?
NO,
WE DON'T HAVE ANY DEBT.
WHAT'S THE PROFIT
ON THE $5.6 MILLION?
SO, PROFIT THIS YEAR
WILL PROBABLY END UP
AT ABOUT $300,000.
-OH.
-BUT YOU GOT TO KEEP IN MIND
I'M NOT TRYING TO SKIM
PROFIT OFF THE TABLE.
I'M REINVESTING IN R&D RIGHT NOW
TRYING TO TAKE THIS THING
AS BIG AS POSSIBLE.
WAIT, WAIT, OKAY.
BUT JEFF, WHERE DOES --
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
YEAH, 'CAUSE YOU'VE GOT
ALL THIS MARGIN.
YOU SHOULD BE MAKING
A MILLION DOLLARS PLUS.
-HE HAS A LOT OF PRODUCT.
-RIGHT.
-HOW MUCH DO YOU SPEND ON R&D?
-OVER A MILLION DOLLARS.
-WOW.
-OH, WOW.
-WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
-WOW.
THAT'S LITERALLY TOOLING
AND PRODUCT DESIGN.
BECAUSE ACCESSORIES
ARE CONSTANTLY CHANGING.
SO, I LOOK AT IT THIS WAY.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND WHAT'S OCCURRING
IN LET'S SAY
THE ACCESSORIES MARKET
AROUND SMARTPHONES.
-RIGHT.
-APPLE, ANDROID.
AND SO THE GUYS THAT ARE WINNING
THAT HAVE HUGE SCALE.
THEY HAVE A CONSTANT FLOW
OF NEW OFFERINGS GOING
TO RETAIL STORES.
AND OVER TIME,
THEIR MARGINS HAVE DECREASED
BECAUSE THERE'S TONS
OF COMPETITION.
I THINK THE SAME THING'S
GONNA HAPPEN TO YOU.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH RUNNING WITH THE WOLVES.
I MEAN,
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BUT YOU GOT TO GET
A LOT BIGGER A LOT FASTER.
EXACTLY, AND THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE TODAY
SO WE CAN RAMP EVERYTHING UP.
YEAH, BUT I DON'T KNOW --
CONSUMER ELECTRONICS
IS A TOUGH SPACE BECAUSE MARGINS
ALWAYS GET CRUSHED.
I'M LOOKING AT IT THAT WAY.
NOTHING PROPRIETARY.
NOTHING WRONG WITH YOU
AS AN ENTREPRENEUR.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE EIGHT PATENTS
COVERING OUR MOST POPULAR ITEM.
WHAT ARE THOSE?
DOESN'T MEAN POO-POO
IN THIS SPACE
'CAUSE YOU CAN
INNOVATE AROUND IT
AND GET THE NEXT ONE
OUT THE DOOR.
THAT --
THAT'S MY OPINION.
I'M JUST A SHARK TRYING
TO MAKE A BUCK.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
HOW BIG DO YOU THINK
YOU COULD BE?
WHERE DO YOU WANT
TO GET TO?
RIGHT, SO, WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO TALK TO THE BIG-BOX STORES.
SO WE'RE IN 1,200 LOCATIONS
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALL INDEPENDENT SURF SHOPS,
SMALLER-TIME GUYS.
REALLY?
HOW BIG DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN BE WITH THE DRONE MARKET?
THAT BLEW OUR MINDS.
WITH HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE BUYING DRONES NOW
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE BUYING OUR FILTERS,
WE'RE THE BIGGEST THIRD-PARTY
AFTERMARKET DRONE COMPANY
RIGHT NOW.
WHERE DO YOU SEE IT TWO,
THREE YEARS FROM NOW?
TWO, THREE YEARS,
IF WE GET BEST BUY AND HIT
AT, LIKE, R.E.I.,
SPORTS AUTHORITY...
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
...WE CAN EASILY BE
AT $40 MILLION, $50 MILLION.
I SEE THE BIG OPPORTUNITY
IS THE DRONE MARKET.
LIKE YOU SAID,
YOUR PEDAL'S TO THE METAL.
YOU ALREADY KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE, RIGHT?
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
THE RIGHT OFFER,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO WASTE A LOT OF TIME
GOING BACK AND FORTH
WITH THESE OTHER SHARKS.
SO, HERE'S MY OFFER.
♪♪
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT,
BUT MARK IS INTERESTED
IN JEFF'S CAMERA ACCESSORY
COMPANY POLAR PRO.
Cuban: I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
THE RIGHT OFFER,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO WASTE A LOT OF TIME
GOING BACK AND FORTH
WITH THESE OTHER SHARKS.
SO, HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE 500K
AND DO 10%
IF YOU'RE READY
TO SAY GO.
WOW, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S LOOKING FOR.
NOW...
ONE OF MY FAVORITE BUSINESS
TEACHERS AT U.C.S.B.
SAID NEVER DO A DEAL THAT YOU
DON'T HEAR OUT EVERYBODY ELSE,
-SO --
-FAIR ENOUGH.
AND YOU'RE THINKING
SHARKS ARE HUNGRY.
John:
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M NOT --
WE'RE NOT GONNA PLAY GAMES.
HERE'S THE DEAL, MARK.
WHY DON'T WE GO UP
TO 15%?
I'LL COME IN,
I'LL DO ALL THE LICENSING,
AND THEN
WE DO IT TOGETHER AT 15%?
NO, I'M GOOD
WITH WHERE I'M AT.
OKAY.
Herjavec: SO...
WHAT IS YOUR OFFER, DAYMOND?
MY OFFER IS THE $500,000
FOR 15%,
AND I BRING ALL PRODUCT DELIVERY
AND LICENSING EXPERTISE AND
PARTNERSHIPS TO YOU.
JEFF, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU HAVE TWO OFFERS.
♪♪
LORI, YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY?
SHARK FIGHT, SHARK FIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I KIND OF LIKE THIS.
SHARK FIGHT, SHARK FIGHT!
I MEAN,
THIS IS INTERESTING.
I JUST LIKE SKINNING THE GAME,
AND ACCESSORIES ARE HARD
TO GET INTO ALL
THE STORES STRATEGICALLY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A STRATEGIC
PARTNER TO GET THEM IN
AND TO HAVE A GOOD POSITION
WHERE PEOPLE NOTICE THEM.
SO, I'M WILLING TO OFFER YOU
THE $500,000 ALSO AT 10%.
THANK YOU, LORI.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
O'Leary: ROBERT,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I LOVE FAST GROWTH.
I LOVE THIS STUFF.
I DO, TOO.
I MEAN,
I THINK YOU'RE KILLING IT.
I LOVE HOW
YOU STARTED THE COMPANY.
ARE YOU SPEED DATING
OR GIVING HIM AN OFFER?
I THINK YOU NEED
MORE MONEY THAN $500,000.
I'LL GO ALONG
WITH LORI OR MARK
AND OFFER $500,000
FOR ANOTHER 10%.
I'LL DO $1 MILLION
FOR 17.5%.
OOH,
THE BIDDING HEATS UP.
MARK, ARE YOU IN
ON THAT DEAL WITH ROBERT?
I'D RATHER DO IT MYSELF, BUT
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES, YEAH.
THE TWO OF US AT 500K EACH
FOR 10% EACH.
-I'LL DO IT.
-YEAH, LOVE IT.
♪♪
-LET'S DO IT.
-ALL RIGHT!
HEY!
ALL RIGHT, THIS IS HOW
WE SHAKE HANDS AT POLAR PRO.
-DO A HANG LOOSE.
-YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH!
YOU DID THE WRONG DEAL.
-GOD BLESS, JEFF.
-THANKS, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS,
JEFF-O.
YEE-HOO!
THIS GUY'S
GONNA KILL IT.
I THINK YOU SUCK!
[ LAUGHTER ]
Overall: I FEEL AWESOME.
I'M SO STOKED RIGHT NOW.
I JUST MADE A DEAL
WITH MARK AND ROBERT.
NOT ONLY DID I GET
WHAT I WAS ASKING FOR,
I GOT TWICE AS MUCH
AS I WAS ASKING FOR.
SO FIRED UP.
GONNA BE HUGE.
♪♪